hey everybody and welcome to a hyped
wild ride with Stevo we've got Jasper
Dolphin the hype man for Tyler the
Creator he's my jackass comrade you know
I'm from Loiter Squad odd future I mean
the kid is a bona fide star and just so
laid back about everything well strap on
your seatbelts because we're gonna get
into all things jackass all things Odd
Future and all things Jasper Dolphin get
hyped and let's get into it
I'm just gonna
[__] yeah I just got that
convicted melon yeah yeah
who's it the spirit
how it took you so long
then he still sends emails without the
subject line dude not anymore I don't
dude
it's just in your junk mail I'm like bro
you know you got a [__] oh they all
say no subject I'm like dude
dude
I put this little toaster yeah is it
gonna Wander from you know what why
don't you switch that button let me
let me when you're on your left now
will you do some workers
not steal this one uh
um coffee uh is there anything even in
there not really I just didn't want to
uh explain this myself okay
ladies and gentlemen Jasper Dolphin that
is I I am him I'm Timothy yeah dude is
that really the name on your license
dolphin no I actually made that name up
Jasper's not my real name
wow yeah I'm a fibber breaking news
what's your real name
yeah what happened to my real name yeah
um I think I just ditched it for a while
I thought he still uses it all right no
actually I was saying what is your real
name
it was already on the internet Devon
Lamar Wilson the whole thing full
government okay and uh taking your dad's
real name is not dark shark no his real
name is
kind of like Compton but compston okay
what's on your Wikipedia Amal Wikipedia
yeah um it says Jasper Dolphin then real
name okay yeah
interesting good I'm excited about this
man and it took so long to do it so yeah
we was I was gone then you were gone now
we're both here
apologies for taking so long to make
this happen and thank you so much for
doing it oh yes no problem the the last
of the
uh official principal cast members of
the jackass franchise it's a clean sweep
we got Jasper
and um
I was uh thinking before we started
recording like am I gonna say this and
people are going to take it the wrong
way but
um I'm gonna say it of the new cast
members
um
I think that you because you were
already established with Tyler the
Creator and odd future and Loiter Squad
like you've already had a career yeah in
your own right and
um
a little bit more so Rachel Wolfson you
know because she's got her stand up yeah
I think YouTube you and Rachel are well
positioned to have taken the opportunity
to be in jackass forever and manage it
effectively
and um thank you
yeah for sure
and um
what I would worry about people taking
the wrong way is uh you know I I feel
with with poopies and Zach that they're
they're less equipped because they were
less established yeah four you know they
they weren't as well established before
and as such they were less equipped to
take advantage of the opportunity and um
it's it's tough to
it's it's for me probably the scariest
thing in the world to imagine being
famous and struggling to make ends meet
yeah I feel that 100 because I'm outside
in everybody see something else but it's
not that all the time
right so uh so yeah I'm not I'm not I
don't mean that in any disparaging way
I'm just uh I I feel for for for the the
guys that I see as less equipped but but
you uh what's been going on since the
movie came out
um well after the movie came out I was a
World Tour
um DJ for uh Tyler or whatever I miss DJ
so we did uh America
Australia we did like the UK and Europe
and all that stuff and that was a blast
tour is always fun and then came back
home been working on my clothing brand
last call I was one of my main focus
right now trying to get that going and
then
um I always like to talk about stuff
that's not there but I would like for
this something to happen with me and
dark shark showing the world what we can
do together on our own time we're gonna
see where that goes I don't want to
speak things that's not fully there it's
just more of a idea that's being pushed
to being something but yeah is that an
idea that you're developing and pursuing
with Tremaine because I gotta believe
that Tremaine would be all over that
yeah yeah for sure
yeah yeah do you call your dad dad or
dark shark
I call him dark shark to piss him off
okay clearly my dark chocolate don't
call me that that's my stage name like
no you say your name more than anybody I
know every video he makes it ends with
dark shark and I'm like you love the
name so now I gotta call it to you every
time answer the phone I'm like What's Up
dark shark that's your dad a character
and Loiter Squad yeah we had brought him
in on Lord of squad to do a couple of
things he did some great things on there
actually and then that's how his name
happened it was like the first time you
bought him on set he just met Shawna and
uh Jeff and he was like you know him
he's goofy he was like you my son your
name is uh Joshua Darfield I'm gonna be
uh I'm gonna be dark shark and then bam
stuck ran with it he gave it that's so
good
I guess it should be a little bit weird
if anybody else came yeah
sure yeah sir so when you're on tour
with Tyler it's just straight Arena Rock
I like yeah this um my bad I'm gonna cut
you off go ahead I'm awful yeah this
tour was um all arenas let me smack the
smack the mic you know as his career
gets higher and
um Arenas get bigger and it's pretty
crazy the shows are like he's an amazing
performer he's really good there's a lot
of the rap people don't know how to
perform that well nowadays they just
like kind of play the track and like
dance on stage but like he performs just
like actual performing for real so
that's always cool to see the homies do
they think how many shows did you guys
do on the world tour that's a good
question because I don't be paying
attention um it was a nice amount it was
for sure like
I was on Guess in between 40 and 60. oh
[__] because it was like we hit like all
the like popular states in California I
mean California America and all the
cooler places in Europe and then we did
uh
uh both of the coaches of Australia and
then
we never made it back to Japan I thought
we was going back to Japan this tour but
I guess that didn't happen but maybe
next time give a favorite place
um like in the states or out of States
out of States out of States it's hard to
just pick one but I can name like a
couple places I love to go I like London
a lot I like Copenhagen
um Japan was really really cool
honestly everywhere I love Australia
great times out there I can't even say
like it's nowhere I really been I like
hate it I used to hate Finland only
because of what happened when I was in
Finland I got pepper spray for the first
time I used to [__] hate Finland but
I'm never going back what did you do to
get pepper spread oh man long story
short it's um we play the festival
um Kimberly was called bills in Finland
and then after this show we went back to
our hotel which was like had like a lake
like in it outside of it so we like had
some girls we went skinny dipping in the
lake and on the way back in the security
guards at the hotel was tripping on us
it was like you guys can't bring the
girls back with y'all we like why can't
we bring like people back with us from
our show blah blah and then from there
so it was like all of us on tour so some
of my friends you know they got anger
problems that starts to fight they start
shuffling I try to step in the middle as
a good guy like hey everybody chill
let me spray straight to the eye and I'm
just I don't there's anger problems and
then there's eroticized rage
then there's then there's like a natural
reaction to the crime of sea blocking
yeah for sure yeah they for sure with C
blocking after you've already seen them
naked too yeah like we cold we just want
to go inside and just chill in the rooms
now yeah that's how they are in Europe
sometimes they're like nope can't come
in here because you're not a guest and
you're just like are you [__] kidding
yeah I'm like bro we had like hella
rooms there too because it's like
everybody had their own rooms it was
like we got probably like 10 to 12 rooms
here plus like tour managers and stuff
and you're gonna give us a problem yeah
I don't know and they the pepper sprayed
the guy is trying to bring peace yeah
that's uh that's not cool because in my
head I'm like don't fight nowhere that's
not in America because you don't want to
go to jail somewhere else I'm like I
mean like you know calm the situation
down yeah I'm sitting here boiling over
it Finland
no more
uh when you're I got a question when
you're touring with Tyler
um is it with the whole Odd Future as a
collective or is odd future still a
thing
um or is it just Tyler it's just him
yeah it's well at first it was um I was
just hype man Travis Taco was DJ and he
will perform but then try to start doing
more stuff with um with movies and
television and stuff like that so then I
started becoming a DJ so now it's just
me and him on tour plus you know all the
production and all that stuff but yeah
sweet
and uh the straight Arena rocking yeah
um and and how did the whole Loiter
Squad thing come about like if anybody
that only knows you from Jackass you
were in the jackass fold yeah uh before
jackass forever because you did a TV
show with Jeff Tremaine and Dick house
and yeah
um some people uh affectionately
referred to it as black asses yes that
was that a lot of people did call it did
we actually had a skit in there that was
called black ass and we like kind of did
like jackass stuff in it oh you guys did
a lot of Jackass I mean not like it was
in the pranks and stuff yeah and you
were surprisingly physical and stunty
you've also got a history as a
skateboarder you kind of rip yeah
skateboarder and I used to like go to
trampoline places not like not a
flippery whale so I know to use my body
even though I'm kind of thicker than
others I could not have used this thing
I remember on the uh what was it on the
the opening of Jackass 4.5 they like
wrapped you up in uh oh in a rope and
then it was detached to a truck yeah the
uh four-wheeler ATV yeah
that that looked awful to me but luckily
it didn't hurt though it looked crazy
than it felt though like as I watched it
I'm like I could have been bad like my
legs was like flying I could have broke
something I don't know
yeah I mean the older I get the more
nervous I am about like spinal cord
stuff yeah and that that made me very um
and and
shoe with the uh the fans all set up
with the parachute man he went for that
yeah I did a full-on next side slide
thing when I landed it was nice though
no pain either I was good man did you
have any injuries filming
um
the the day we did the sand the beach
the intro I don't know what I did but I
pulled something in my neck area and I
couldn't look like to the right fully
for like a week but I wasn't doing
nothing crazy though like I don't even
remember why I remember getting home and
then next day I just kind of just felt
sore and I was like my neck is a little
tight but I don't remember getting hurt
I remember you doing a lot of front
flips that day yeah there was a lot of
front flips on the balls and stuff yeah
the Beast balls in the half sand so uh
what
I mean I guess like like you were super
physical what was that was was Tyler
like crazy stunty on boiler Squad
um yeah I would say yeah it wasn't too
crazy stunning but like he he's like a
freak of nature athlete athletic guy
like he could dunk the basketball but
don't know how to dunk the basketball he
could jump up there and dunk it but no
swag to it though okay and he could jump
super high and everything most of my
friends are pretty athletic you know
what I'm saying we used to like be
outside for real like skateboarding
climbing Gates doing just anything that
was fun back in the day let me tell you
back in the day when I was a kid I used
to gobble down boxes of cereal like it
was no big deal and I was ingesting
hundreds of grams of sugar in a single
sitting I'm sure and these days that is
not the case I'm actually back on my
best behavior and feeling so good about
my diet avoiding sugar and the secret to
my success is Magic spoon zero grams of
sugar keto friendly you've got 13 to 14
grams of protein per serving and did I
mention it is delicious I mean it's like
a guilty pleasure that you're not even
guilty about it's absolutely so
wonderful and wait until you try the
cocoa the Frosted peanut butter fruity
and the limited edition flavors they've
got coming your way peaches and cream oh
man it's just endless awesomeness I
don't even have a box of the fruity
flavor because I love it so much I just
crushed it before we even got to
recording today I just love this stuff
and if you go to magicspoon.com
Stevo then you can try yourself a bundle
of a variety of flavors they're so sure
you're gonna love it it's backed with a
100 happiness guarantee if you don't
love it they will refund you your money
but be sure to use the promo code Stevo
at checkout to enjoy five dollars off
your order again I love it I eat it I
recommend it so go to magicspoon.com
Stevo and let's get back to it so yeah
yeah and what did that show Loiter Squad
like did that just Elevate the profile
of the music like on a crazy level where
that's when things popped up and got
really big well it didn't I want to say
elevated the music because it was like
the music was here and the show was like
you know something that was like in
between the group thing but if it sure
brought different fans in different
worlds to like people that watch you
know don't swim the the music for sure
because like we for sure song was like
who are these guys let me see what
they're about then you get the music but
yeah right so so basically you're saying
that the music did not need loiter's
Squad I don't think so not for the music
but but it helped though it helped if I
could remember correctly the music side
of it was already huge yeah yeah
it came out yeah it was already like
touring and uh shows and how many
seasons did you do uploaders you did
three good seasoning order Squad and
then we uh we almost made another show
from uh a skit called popo that was in
Lord of squad that we actually filmed
with Sean and Jeff but it never made it
it's in the uh the hidden files I guess
you would say what was it about it why
didn't it make them we had a show called
uh I mean my battle show it was a skit
called Popo's where Lionel and Tyler
were dressed up as cops and just do you
know dumb stuff like 901 Reno and
the guy from um the hair guy Laszlo at
uh dos swim I know where he was like I
don't really like a sketch comedy like
can you guys try just making this a show
and he was like all right let's just do
it like why not so he made the pilot it
came out and I don't know like it just
never happened I don't know I thought it
was good I think somebody didn't like
the voice probably kept putting on his
Batman voice like he's like I don't know
why but he really wanted to be like my
new character talks like this and I
don't think the head dude really liked
it and then they just go back and forth
on meetings and then yeah no show so it
wasn't a question of it being like
wildly controversial oh no no it wasn't
that I think that's something to do with
a phone call and somebody might have
just spoke a little crazy to somebody
else I don't go too deep into it but
just to say somebody use the n-word that
somebody wasn't Inward and they probably
didn't like that
I'm not sure I followed that all the way
through but I heard enough to kind of
get it
um all right so and how long have you
known Tyler
um
to I don't know years exactly but I was
what 15. like 15 when I I moved to cross
street from actually uh but I think I've
seen them before that because we used to
go to the same skate park uh Hawthorne
skate park a eucalyptus part is called
the Dirty I like the name like the
street name but that was the kick it's
about yards to skate at and stuff back
in the day he's better at skating oh me
of course I think I'm the best one in
our future escape and besides not kill
Smith because he is a pro skater but
other than that yes all right yeah I've
seen you I've seen you throw down
um what uh
where do you put Shark Week like we're
at on your resume
um yeah I don't know but a great place
because that was amazing that was so
much fun and it's on I honestly I think
about it sometimes like what we filmed I
was like it's actually really really
crazy like she could go bad at any time
like it's not a joke and then when it
went bad
yeah seriously crazy like it was a big
joke to us yeah for sure were you on the
boat when poopy's got bit Yeah I was a
little silent afterwards though it was
just it was crazy how it just happened
because it was like he landed he was
like yeah poopies and then you just see
this shark like come up he's like ah and
it's just red see his hand come out of
the water it was like this is crazy so
what happens when something like that
happens do you guys continue filming for
the day or do you just cut and
um they kept filming on the boat on just
kind of the aftermath of that situation
but it did not go and and that was kind
of why the why it happened in the first
place is because sharks tend to attack
at dawn and dusk yeah and as the light
went lower and lower we thought you know
yes
I mean 100 everything about that was
awful yeah that was actually the the one
more like that was the last time we was
gonna try it and that's when it went bad
one more time well how many times you
guys tried that I mean I don't they
pulled them a couple of times because at
first the jacket was too much and he
couldn't do it like a jacket and then it
was it I started getting too uh choppy
in the water for him to get pulled on
the jet ski and then yeah that was the
last one and then the shark was like I
got something for you yeah poopies loves
that it happened to him dude for sure
this is a gnarly thing the scar
everything not many people get is this
no who's I don't and three people I know
have been bitten by a shark you know
what I mean worldwide even worse than me
yeah
um yeah
seems to have gotten to a place where
it's not
um like traumatic messing him up like I
mean I just saw he posted on Instagram
like a sick deep Barrel oh yeah I mean
he's surfing is the one thing that he's
like truly passionate about and like if
he's getting pitted like that you know I
mean he's getting barreled then life is
good for people well I didn't even think
it did affect him I mean sure it
affected him really bad but then when he
did that video and he just started
breaking down and crying and I was like
oh [__] like oh yeah yeah because it was
always been like you know him on
Instagram like yeah what's up but then
first time talking about he just melted
probably really hit he probably never
had a deep conversation about it besides
like I got bit what's going on guys yeah
yeah a real conversation he probably
start having flashbacks and like
thinking about it probably what was your
reaction when you found out that uh they
were gonna do another shark week I was
like honestly I was happy I had a good
time like sharks aren't they're very
crazy not crazy but like you know you
play with nature you just you go bad but
they're actually cool like I have a
different respect I like sharks way more
than I did before because like back in
the day you would think like you see a
shark in the water it's gonna kill you
right away and jump on the boat it's
gonna murder you ah it's not even like
that like right
in hindsight we really did ask for that
attack to happen and like had we not
asked for it to happen like it would
have been fine they've been doing Shark
Week for 30 years yeah and and that's
the first time anything
in like 30 years actually yeah
it had to be us it wouldn't make sense
with somebody else yeah
right I I can tell you that my reaction
when they reached out about a second
Shark Week I I thought man you know guys
I've really kind of lost my sense of
humor for being irresponsible around
sharks
and Tremaine said oh no this this time
we're gonna be totally responsible and I
was like the only thing that sounds
worse than uh like more danger with
sharks is being safe around them
[Laughter]
yeah like I was like wow that sounds
terrible to me I don't want to be
dangerous around sharks and I don't want
to be safe around them either like I
think I'm just like I'm out on shark
yeah it is crazy because I even did the
uh can I do the the late night dive we
like went back at night time and did the
Disco line and in my head I'm just like
from last time remember just like night
time they attack nighttime they hunt
nighttime I'm just like I'm a fool I'm
about to be in the middle of it at night
time I think it's more Dusk and Dawn
like once it's dark dark I think you're
cool it wasn't super dark when I first
went in the sun was like setting so it
was around the same time
oh yeah that's not that's nice crazy
clothes on what kind of sharks were they
um they got poopies are yeah yeah those
are sharks top four most dangerous bro
it was delicious I seen him attack a
leaf first off I don't know where the
leaf came from
that wasn't your first indication of
like oh they might be hungry the
indications were all over the place man
I mean you we were throwing meat as soon
as the meat lands
it was it was like a a super fake
over-the-top Piranha movie like except
they weren't piranhas They were sharks
sharks
how many were there like 50 to 100 not
hundreds it was a it was like okay at
one point in time we could probably get
like around like 20 around swimming all
around and stuff I feel like it was like
something like that
I'm saying easy 20.
to 30. yeah because there was times
where they were just swimming around but
then there'll be times we was filming it
all come into one area and it's like
some are like smarter than others they
like see stuff and they're like I'm not
going over there I don't want to buy
those people yeah was it like when we go
to Fiji and they you could do a shark
dive and they know that they're getting
fed or is this like you guys just
started chumming the [__] middle of
the ocean random Waters where they just
I I don't know I don't I don't know I
just know that they were aggressive as
though I've never seen aggression on
that level speak aggression in the ocean
can I just tell you how upsetting it is
all of the plastic that is destroying
the world and how happy I am that liquid
death is here to save the day with their
infinitely recyclable aluminum cans and
how about this company when we started
with them they had Mountain Water and
sparkling water then they came out with
the flavors buried alive mango chainsaw
severed lime and Now ladies and
gentlemen they have the most delicious
tea out there they've got rest in Peach
armless Palmer and Grim leafer plus keep
an eye out for the convicted melon I'm
telling you man this company is on fire
they're saving the world I love them and
their new Iced Teas are available on
Amazon with free shipping plus same deal
with retailers near you and has a
special treat to the Wild Ride listeners
you get 20 off of any apparel order at
liquiddeath.com
Stevo for your first order of apparel
their apparel is awesome everything they
do is awesome liquid death I love you
listeners of the wild ride I love you
I'm so happy to put you together
everybody go enjoy your liquid death
it's at liquiddeath.com
Stevo now let's get back to it
yeah they were I was around bull sharks
and the bull shark wasn't moving like
them yeah they were moving like bad kids
I used to throw some candy in all the
kids
Pinata Party yes yeah dude um so uh
now when when you're doing the DJ stuff
how much of that is like creating
like original music uh no original music
at all because it's like
the lights and the music and
everything's all together so I'm just
kind of doing playback or whatever like
hype Manning too so you know I'm hitting
the lyrics playing the song stopping
them starting at the right time letting
songs flow into the other it's like a
nothing too crazy but you still got to
pay attention to what you're doing out
there right no no new music though
um do you create original music
separately on your own no I try I try to
make a mixtape back in
2008 or nine and I made two songs and I
realized like I don't know I want to be
a rapper I don't like this that much
okay did you put those out huh did you
put those out no they would never come
out they never came out yeah I'm on a
couple of songs but that was my first
time actually trying to make my own
category of music yeah you were on a
couple songs on Goblin right yeah yeah
Tucson the gobland in the uh actual uh
future mixtape I'm on there and then
some other ones you made your own genre
of music for me would you say you said
you made your own oh no I tried to make
my own like mixtape my own okay album
whatever and I made two songs like rap
songs and I just gave them I was like
it's not for me go back to skateboarding
and just having a good time yeah if only
I would have done that
[Music]
[Laughter]
when I hear DJ that feels like more kind
of in the Wheelhouse nope actually I'll
take that back one of those songs that I
made back in the day was on when the
Beats I made that's when I really
realized I shouldn't be making beats I
was terrible
all right you know I'm like legit like
the playback guy like
the start the first song he comes out
talk I already like know he's about to
kind of say you ready to cue the next
song stopping it in time all that stuff
but I I don't know the DJ word is kind
of weird because you ever see a DJ DJ
needs to be turning off for no reason
yeah that's just fake my homie told me
you ain't got to turn knives all the
time
I just sometimes you might want to fix a
little something so it sounds better but
like they'd be up there just fly into
the crowd
it's already pre-mixed yeah it's most of
the time yes I knew it dude I've even
seen a video where somebody had like it
was on like logic because like the whole
track was already there like it already
like flowed and like they didn't even
like change the song because someone
actually bring another song in and mix
it together for sure I seen one where it
was already like together together where
they were just harder to do what they
were just act like they push buttons and
act like they knew when a drop was
uh-huh it's cheat code out there yeah I
wonder if like Steve aoki's doing that
or like dead mouse never know I mean
there's uh DJ iPod like musical acts
I'm hearing more and more it is reported
that there are high level music musical
acts out there pretending to play their
instruments
I got well Milli Vanilli didn't even
wasn't even them in the studio recording
in the first place so at least the
exactly their lips
it wasn't even them in the studio like
like uh they were never
made music that was the problem with
Millie Vanilli I can't do these other
acts that they'll record a track that
they're happy with and then let that be
every concert oh really really oh that's
poo you have anybody you want to call
out I mean
it has been alleged
that spit it out
according to TMZ
according to certain people
um there are elements of
Motley Crue
oh my God maybe he's too [__] up to
play
their uh their world I don't know if I
believe it
yeah
that's some comments on a video about it
saying that like giving Vince Neil's
vocals
I think nobody would pre-record that
um but I I love Motley Crue I love
Motley Crue I love Vince Neil I love all
these guys I don't know what's going on
I think uh that these are merely
allegations allegations we'll never know
the world would never know yep
um what uh like what other stuff do you
have going on like is there like acting
like uh acting
um right now not fully acting
I'm sure I really wanted I was working
on a cartoon but I really want to make
an anime like Japanese style cartoon I
think that's my next thing I really want
to get into and I got to figure out who
I need to meet to make that happen that
does that type of world and animation
because like I watched a lot of anime
I'm like why not just go and make my own
what would be your role in that you
would voice it I would like to write it
I'm gonna be down and do voices probably
not the main character but like just
random voices and for sure write it and
be in a room on the animation and stuff
for sure if you ever watch anime porn no
I have not but I see you take it back it
was that one whips it wasn't even porn
it was a stupid website like in like
when he was in middle school and he was
like who's it called e-bombs world that
was Dragon Ball Moon Moon ball something
it was like Dragon Ball Z and Sailor
Moon they had like a website I remember
people used to post that [__] back in
the day at school and I was like what
the hell is this this is nuts yeah cause
I always thought it was weird like
people would watch like anime porn and
I'm like do you watch anime porn some
guy was like [__] yeah
just seen the pictures that they posted
from back in the day yeah like the first
world of that I've never even seen it
before I wouldn't even know where to
begin it was like Dragon Moon some dumb
website back in the day like this is
like junior high school days so probably
long gone by now
I've never seen him yeah I've seen it of
course I've seen it you ever no okay
come on like what do you think I am
a certain type no everybody has their
thing Minnie over here poles dude did
you see the the girl Vinnie just hooked
up with no
[Music]
I'll show you after all right I'll leave
that there yeah that's the hottest girl
I've ever seen in my life how about if
we go with no edits on this podcast
I mean you're already talking about me
selling heroin yeah yeah that's the
worst thing you've done right yeah for
sure
yeah when you were in Australia it was
seven to eight oh yeah yeah but I've
been getting DMS from so many people
asking if I still have heroin
I never seen it in person it's either
white or brown it's powder I've seen
like in movies I've never even seen it
seen it yeah well on the East Coast what
is it powder and then here's black tar
black tar yeah
smells like ginger ginger I'm a sushi
place yeah that's why people like it
it's a lot better on the East Coast
yeah what's the most weight you've ever
pushed in one sale
[Music]
[Laughter]
speaking of rehab you had another uh
interesting thing you told me before
yeah so I was in rehab in 2011 and yeah
and I was only allowed one CD and one CD
player and I chose Goblin I listened to
[__] Goblin over and over and over
again which is like I remember the
success from that album yeah did you
guys know like before like making that
album before releasing it did you guys
know it was gonna explode the way that
it did honestly man those days I was
really just living in life I didn't
really know how big we were until later
on like I didn't I didn't look at
magazines interviews all that like you
know hip-hop stuff about like music I
was just literally just picking my
skateboard up hanging out my friends
playing shows and having a good time I
really didn't know I I think back in
like 2018 I went back and watched videos
about us and I was like God damn people
really [__] with us but uh they still
do but uh yeah no I was literally just
living in the moment like 100 like just
[__] yeah what year was that 2011. so
that came out in 2011. yeah
yeah and I remember when the video came
out for Yonkers I mean we filmed it and
everything oh man that video was like
nothing I've never seen before it was
insane you know she went crazy yeah real
fast yeah wow she's been killing it for
a while well I wasn't that wasn't my
view that was his video but that started
like it for sure took things to the next
level for the whole group of friends
yeah because your mixtapes before Goblin
they had some success yeah yeah random
yeah because I remember listening to
those too yeah
the debut album for Tyler yeah but then
we had the Odd Future mixtape was album
with all of us on it I did like two
songs on there or something like that
then we had other mixtapes too I did
like a song or so but yeah hip hop
Jasper is Dead come back
wow that that's uh that's great man
Vinnie's a big fan over here yeah for
sure yeah and he thanks dude
Show us the picture and get our reaction
to the chick no
so I'll show you we won't show the
camera but just check this chick out and
this is like
constantly then he's the man it's one
after another
he shows me okay look at this
and he's the man
I know her
okay Vinnie
oh dude
he'd be fighting a bit dude Instagram
the low-key followers twos yeah don't
say she might not be too big
to be clear I am not prepared to say
that Vinnie's habit of scoring super hot
chicks is a bad habit I will definitely
say that he does have other habits that
are very bad habits which I think that
he needs to stop and the answer when you
have a bad habit that you need to stop
is fume why because instead of vapors
they're using flavored Air instead of
electronics we're all natural over here
instead of harmful chemicals we've got
completely natural flavors from awesome
essential oils I'm telling you it's
amazing and I don't even have any bad
habits I'm particularly trying to quit I
just enjoy my fume
I really do and uh and keep it in my
pocket all the time I get super bummed
if I lose it
um I don't know it's just something I
enjoy and it is very very useful when it
comes to knocking off bad habits so go
to try fume.com that's
t-r-y-f-u-m.com slash Stevo and use the
promo code Stevo at checkout you will
not only get a great deal but you'll get
an additional 10 off your order because
you are a listener of the Wild Ride
podcast once again that's trifum.com
Stevo and use the promo code Stevo at
checkout for 10 off your order now let's
get back to it that's uh she's cute it
doesn't make sense I don't know that is
funny guys for sure what a world yeah
I'm like serious like people like oh
you'll be having cute girls I'm like I'm
funny
and I laugh they like you treat me you
legit make girls laugh and treat them
like people because dudes there's a lot
of dudes out there that don't know how
to treat women don't know how to talk to
girls be around them and just be on some
normal [__] and when you give them that
they'd be like oh like you're cool like
I want to [__] you now sometimes but
yeah who's better with women you were
dark shark
um I don't know what the [__] did I
started redoing
that's great so I'm gonna say me I have
no idea it's been with one girl for a
long time well we recently broke up oh
yeah yeah that happened in life I'm
sorry I'm just it's okay life happens
you know what I'm saying right I mean I
gotta believe that you're gonna be okay
yeah no matter what happens yeah we both
okay she's good I'm good like we have an
understanding of like humans and older
people it's just like all right like we
don't hate each other we're cool say
what's up no biggie all right so I
should always be that's good so now are
you just like on a uh dating app no no
no no no dating that for me I'm not on
Ryan has been chilling yeah I remember
like I went to a party and I was just
like why am I even out right now I just
want to go home I'm on my like older
like not even not that old but I'm on my
chill stuff now like how old are you 32
all right so like I don't really care to
go out I wear the drink at home if I do
drink but I don't ever drink like that
no more I have to relax I'm gonna relax
here
I'm like 32. is that higher or lower
than your body count
that's a good question my body count for
sure is higher than that I was a wild
man them first tours
I Can Only Imagine first tested the uh
the groupie thing that was crazy I was
like I see I literally tested it it was
a girl she wanted to get on the tour bus
and take photos and I was like you want
to come on the bus like what's up and
she was like I'll suck your dick and I
was like let's see what happens and I
was like is that easy and Tori became a
[__] you know a party
that's crazy it's dangerous though you
never know that's crazy thank God it
didn't how long did that like kind of a
Vibe because it just seemed like just
such a chill dude like you're not really
um I was a wild man for a while I was
like the first like seven years of uh
the uh the fame or whatever you want to
call it being noticed by the word I
would say I like to use the word famous
because I don't feel like I'm really
famous I'm just a young black man living
a nice life yeah I think that's that's
fair to say like uh I I I think I don't
like to use the word famous too much
because I don't think I'm that big
LeBron James is famous right you know
what I'm saying I'm Jasper
yeah like we're successful enough to
have a comfortable life but we don't
have like uh Paparazzi chasing us around
and if we say something crazy it's not
gonna be a big headline you don't you
don't want to cancel somebody they don't
know unless it's about bam yeah say
something about damages [__] makes if
bam sneezes three times it's like makes
a you know Vanity Fair headline like
they want to see stuff that they don't
see you know anything that's gonna make
people look you know how that goes they
just try to grab anything as a headline
yeah but um man it's crazy
so you're you're single and
like
not on a dating app nope nope what's a
day in the life look like for you
um I wake up
it depends on what I got to do if I got
something to do I'll wake up early and
then like smoke a lot of joint probably
watch a little anime or whatever show
I'm watching at the time maybe play the
game for a second and then go out do
what I got to do for a business or
whatever hang out with my friends if I
do see them get some food back home
before not too late and then I just kind
of relax for the rest of the night watch
shows I like or play some games or I'll
go out every once in a while but what
games are you playing
um right now what are you playing I
started playing fortnite I didn't used
to play that game and somehow it got me
but uh I play literally everything that
comes out like recently they had a God
of War I play a lot of 2K The Last of Us
the Spider-Man games really a little bit
of everything you're on Twitch uh yeah I
have a twitch oh wow is that lucrative
for you or is that just for fun or is it
just I get on I've been on Twitch a
couple of times I don't necessarily love
to be on Twitch because I feel like
playing video games like my chill time I
don't want if somebody is like looking
at me and I gotta talk and like hey
what's up like what's up guys like I'm
playing the game it's me I literally
just like relax and play the games and
like just talk to my homies in the
headphones about normal life stuff yeah
but it's cool I told myself I'm trying
to get home two times at least three
times a week on Twitch but I failed
I got it though yeah
um Vinnie how many girls do you think
you [__] this week
how many this week uh one you just say
that with confidence
you're a liar
bro
am I putting you on blast a little bit
okay sorry dude
no it's cool man when I hear about this
more girls gonna want you because now
they're gonna be wondering like what is
he packing like all the cuties it's
nothing much dude I'll tell you that
right now yeah it's a nice guy yeah what
do you think it is dude it's the eyes
it's 100 the eyes I'll admit that one
what about the uh the one and was it
Boise Jesus yeah Boise yeah
happening there no there's nothing
really happening there we still talk now
and then I mean dude the standards keep
getting higher and higher good I know
you can beat them anymore
yeah
that's crazy man what's your Instagram
so girls can find you skinny Benny
skinny man
skinny Vinnie if I didn't hear that
so you smoke weed every day uh yes
except for sometimes I'm on tour I don't
smoke just because of some time the weed
is not good at places and I just rather
not okay you don't just switch it up the
hashish
um
I did smoke some house last tour but I
don't know I wasn't really I'm not
really looking for weed I'm on tour when
I'm in like out of the country like I go
to New York I'm a tour I'm definitely
getting some good weed but I'm in
Australia I'm like uh what's that thing
you've been to New York because they're
just selling it out of Ziploc bags on a
[__] fold-out table on the corner of
like oh you can get them at like bodegas
and stuff I heard
I went there like four months ago with
my mom and they just put a table on the
corner of Times Square just bags of weed
out there like what you want what you
want it's legal they're recreational I
know it was like that it was crazy wow I
mean it was kind of like before it was
legal anywhere New York was the one
place where you just have a delivery
service like they bring it to you in a
little plastic box yeah you ever get in
trouble for those drugs out in New York
um you've had some fun times in New York
yeah I don't remember getting in trouble
for scary
drugs in New York now how are you guys
touring around uh on a bus or taking PJs
in America is on a bus and then uh it
was PJs and regular flights in Europe I
usually uh we'll stay like for instance
like we'll stay in London for a little
while and then fly to the other parts
and your shows and then come back and
like that'll be our Hub like our stay
spot that's cool you guys sell a ton of
merch at your shows yeah the merch do go
crazy
a little bit
that's good yeah halfway taking over
next time it's that Jasper Dolphin merch
at the shows no it's uh the brand is
called last call I started a while ago
it's not like Jasper Dolphin but it's
just different cool designs like this
one just has an alien
all right I like aliens is a dolphin
your spirit animal
um
I don't think so why'd you how'd it come
up with Dolphin did you say that in the
beginning uh the dolphin Park came out
of nowhere literally um
I couldn't figure out what to put my
last name on uh Facebook because you
gotta you have to put a last name and I
wanted to be like just Jasper like seal
or Madonna and then I don't know why we
just put dolphin and then it just it
stuck and ran with it we made shirts out
of it clothes
and now I'm just Jasper Dolphin now but
I'm trying to drop the dolphin and go
back to being like sealed just Jasper
all right like Stevo yeah
Donna share Stevo
it sounds like uh yeah maybe because
you're you're a young buck you know that
you can fly through the air and you know
get yanked by an ATV for four wheelers
and and not get injured but um like have
you gotten hurt doing stunts
um I never got hurt doing stunts at work
but like off of work yeah I dislocated
my ankle and fractured my leg at the
trampoline place once that was terrible
yeah like my foot my left ankle foot was
pointing straight left and it was
looking real ugly so I grabbed it and I
twisted back into place and then like
popped within you do that yourself yeah
cool I couldn't look at it like I I
failed I think I broke my leg and
everybody's like what are you talking
about and I like flipped over and it was
just bad
bro and I just like literally just
and you're like and it just went back in
place but then it was just dislocated
like it was not together it was like
hanging for sure yeah it's like biting
your own finger off like that awesome it
didn't hurt until after I did that like
I saw it I'm like oh this is bad then I
popped it then the pain came
ah when are you taking a nap did they
pitch any ideas to you in the movie that
you were just like no I don't want to do
that
um only thing I didn't want to do was
the bull thing but luckily we didn't
have to do it right they were they were
coming out of all of us yeah it was uh
everyone you're gonna dress up like
sunflowers and just be in the middle of
the bull ring and like uh
don't be in it and like nobody wanted to
be in it and that was like uh the second
shoot on the day when the first shoot
was Knoxville with the magician thing
yeah and and uh that was the same day
right right but the first shoot was Dark
Souls yeah he went off to the hospital
and that was just through a Vibe on the
set we're not doing the sunflower thing
yeah Bulls that's one thing I wrote a
bull ones for uh the show that me and my
friend Arrow did and I told myself I'll
never do anything with Wolves again
because I survived it and I'm like it's
cool we take that w we only know L's
over here right dude we were filming
Wild Boys in Mexico and there was like
some like
I I don't know if it was like a an
annual holiday that involved bulls or if
it was just like some event but it was
like in like a pretty
like small and like rather undeveloped
kind of a shanty tone and they had this
bold thing going on and we watched this
kid he
probably a teenager and and he just got
so savagely mauled by a bullet in front
of us like limp and then the you know
the board just kept scooping him up and
like just like whoa we didn't we didn't
receive confirmation one way or the
other of what the outcome was but in our
view we witnessed somebody
get killed by a bull and like and it was
pretty clear to me
having had that experience and
witnessing that that like I don't want
to have anything to do with bulls and
wild boys was before jackass number two
when Knoxville got in the ring and and
got flipped by the yak and then bought
the Toro totter and and you guys had
Bulls in the intro too right we had
Bulls In the End shirts yeah
and uh I mean this is after that
experience in Mexico I'm like no that's
why like I'm on camera I'm like so
visibly uncomfortable with anything to
do with Bulls I feel you on that you
don't know what can happen they're super
strong and they already like
they get [__] with all day they in
fact the the people that like you know
own them just be [__] with them so
they'd be angry and they're gonna take
all that [__] on you is it true that
when you're on a ball and before they
open the gate they have a rubber band
tied around his nuts and they snap it
or something like that but it wasn't
there for me I heard something about the
the tying their nuts up or some [__] and
then they snap it to make it go [__]
nuts yeah and they don't like throw
darts at it and [__] too or is that just
with like the running of the bulls
I haven't heard any of that stuff but I
hate it yeah that's pretty gnarly
huh trying to get them all worked up
then work on me what was it like getting
called to do jackass it was actually
amazing but scary at the same time but
who called you would they say well I
think it was Shawna that hit me up she
had hit me up and she was like Hey we're
filming a new movie and you might want
to have you come hang out with us and I
was like
yeah I'm like sounds like an amazing
opportunity but
they be doing some [__] that's you know
a little bit above my pay rate yeah
craziness and I was just like all right
I'm down 100 but let's just hope that I
don't lose a neck or anything make it
home safe but yeah it was great it was
amazing everybody was cool from the
staff to meeting everybody I already
knew some people before so yeah it felt
like like a mini home is it is it like
when you're filling out the paperwork if
I was like dude I definitely don't want
to do claustrophobic stuff is that for
sure I'm doing claustrophobic stuff yeah
you can't be forced to do anything like
they well that's not true he
'd set up a thing where you like fall
through a trap door that you don't and
then you're trapped in in some
claustrophobic thing so yeah they like
that though they might spring a prank on
you that forces you into a situation
that you're not comfortable with and
that sucks and that probably would
definitely happen did you have anything
like that on your paperwork like I don't
want to do knock I learned early from
Jeff that you don't tell them what you
don't like you don't tell them what you
do like anything you don't like they're
going to get you with right yeah
bringing part of Silence to the Lambs uh
no because see Jeff asked me it was all
cool with trying to take the uh because
he told me at first it was a snake uh
the head of the cookie without down to
do and I was like [__] it I'll try it
and I guess you took that as like ah
let's not bring them around the steak
being because he's cool with trying it
I'm kind of sad I wasn't in that one
like that [__] was that she was
hilarious
talking about yeah I'll take the cookie
off the snake yeah what about what about
your dad dad he had to go through the
same paperwork to do some of the stuff
like he interviewed him and he he [__]
up early
I don't like that I'm just like you are
a fool so you look at my interview
versus his he's like he tells you what
he's scared of and I'm like I hate [__]
yeah stand really good week
throw up when I see it
yeah Jeff already he already got plans
of [__] with you you gotta you don't
show with what gets you either like
something comes up don't don't Flinch
just act normal because then they see a
little bit of something they gonna run
with that [__] that's so funny man yeah
like other than the Bulls and the
sunflower thing which universally nobody
wanted anything to do with I don't think
that there was anything Jasper wasn't
100 game before you know I was just
decided to say I wouldn't say no to
anything and I foreign kind of know me
and they have like there's certain
things they probably wouldn't even work
with me that was like we ain't even
gonna ask them probably because we
already know that guy but yeah I was
willing to try everything like at some
point he never got uh the pig semen
dumped on you no they didn't get me with
that one yeah they got I saw somebody
get hit with it
that's one that they wouldn't bother
wasting the pigs even on me
this doesn't phase me yeah I'm pretty
good like that like I established early
on that uh that that I'm just down for
like I remember in the very beginning of
uh very beginning of Jackass
um
one of the first emails I ever even sent
um I was like hey I got an idea like
um
I want you to hang me upside down from a
tree and torture me for like 24 hours
something like that and they were like
okay so we're not gonna be pranking
Steve
something like just absolutely absurd I
think I think and there was a a distinct
motivation for it where I had just been
like partying for like so many days
straight
and like then like a bunch of like pills
or something to like go to sleep and
then when I finally did fall asleep
nobody could wake me up I'm like dude
I'm like man dudes I just parted for
this you know so like nobody could wake
me up like when I'm in that state I want
to be hung upside down from a dream
stupid do whatever
you know
and they're like yeah
that got me out of a lot of stuff yeah
for sure I am I'm sure for sure yeah
dude so uh it sounds like uh an average
day is like reasonably mellow at this
point you're going back on tour anytime
soon uh none for the rest of this year
um whenever you decides to drop an album
that's when tour will go back up okay
and are you involved in recording the
album uh no I actually stopped going to
the studio as much as I used to because
I was like it's cool being in the studio
with your friends but at the same time
like I'm not working or doing anything
I'm just kind of just hanging out so I
was just like I can hang out somewhere
else at home right but I still go I'll
pull up to the studio sometimes but
music wise nah why should I take that
back
I am on his last album saying something
random in the background one of the
songs I think was it this album
yeah I think it's this one
what's the other one
I don't know everything's a blur now
right it just happens like that on tour
uh Tyler the Creator has a good
relationship with nardwar you ever meet
nardwar oh yeah yeah we rented him quite
a few times actually it's such a legend
he's cool he's cool I [__] with him
heavy okay that's I was just curious
about it yeah I remember the first time
I've seen him I've ran into him at South
by Southwest it's on the streets
randomly like I wasn't even with like
none of the homies it was just me and
like it was I wit actually I don't know
who the [__] I was with but I seen him
and I was like he's cool and then he
started to interview like my friends and
then us all of us whatever so that was
pretty tight did he ever get you on
anything that you're like how the [__]
did he know that
um
not me no no he didn't even usually
um uh interview who was ever probably
was making the album yeah I was just
trying to be there just kind of just
talking my [__] you know what I'm saying
that's cool yeah we've been quite a few
times though I hugged him from the back
once
all right
when uh
when you're in this like you're at home
you're chilling you're smoking when
you're playing video games do you make
like YouTube content you have a YouTube
channel uh no I don't have a YouTube
channel I haven't made YouTube stuff and
uh since like back in the day like uh
Future YouTube page we have yeah there's
no no YouTube for me right now
all right so so life is chilling man and
and when you're on tour like Garrett
doesn't breaking in money I mean those
shows are huge yeah yeah straight work
it's a it's good work because it's like
it's not too hard it's fun I'm there
with my friends like security guards
like one of my good friends too we love
veal he's the greatest security guard he
might look scary but he's a nice man
all right it was off it's all fun fun
and games
and you guys travel on one bus you and
Tyler
um this recent tour yeah it was just me
and him on the bus and then I think we
had a couple of buses because the tours
are like you know the Productions
everything way bigger than it used to be
so it felt weird it was just me and him
in a book usually it'd be like me him
one of the other homies somebody that
records like video and like security but
security got his own bus now with some
other people so it's different it's cool
crazy man it's crazy I I
I I
envy you having like this laid-back
approach where it's like when you're on
tour you're killing it and you know I
feel like I don't ever I'm never laid
back about anything like I'm always like
I gotta keep even when you sleep you
want people to [__] beat you
and my chillest moments whoop my ass
it's crazy man it's crazy
um you're uh there's the the leaf blower
people you know there's a leaf blowers
Association I did not know that but
thank God
that's good I was just gonna ask what uh
any other stuff you want to promote
um right now besides my sexy face just
me and my brand last call last call
where did people get last call last call
worldwide.com check us out on Instagram
last call worldwide I'm saying that's
main focus doing a pop-up shop we're
doing some stuff with Bodega we trying
to do a pop-up shop in Australia soon so
we'll be out there for you New York
we're coming back with another one all
right and that leaf blower really got us
man so I really own us yeah I'm super
stoked on you man thank you congrats on
your success thank you appreciate it
like welcome to the jackass family and
uh thank you for doing this oh yes no
thank you shout out to everybody shout
out to everybody here you know what I'm
saying shout out to the world that's
right
yeah
mad dude what can we say about Jasper
just the coolest cat man so laid back
such a fun dude I really really wish it
wouldn't have taken so long to get him
on the Wild Ride podcast what else can I
say man
um
you know have you noticed Paul that I'm
doing a better job with my
conversational etiquette
yeah I have noticed yeah yeah I've been
trying man I don't want to be a jerk you
know I don't want to be a jerk I don't
want to alienate listeners I don't want
to rub people the wrong way I want to
just deliver a good podcast man and I'm
trying I really uh like to think I'm
getting better and um
I am as always very grateful for you
guys sticking around and um yeah give
Jasper some love and I'm gonna keep
working on doing a better job at uh
taking you on the Wild Ride yeah it did
foreign